Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it is the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
June 17th,
2013 here when I added something there.
I as you just say,
it's the Monday morning podcast and I went,
it is the Monday morning podcast as if to suggest that I'm even more impressed
with myself this week than I usually am.
How are you guys doing?
How's your Monday?
Yeah,
it's,
you have a bad one.
Oh it's okay.
Cause there's always Tuesday.
What you guys to go for actually wrote a show tune about Tuesday.
It was a blatant ripoff of Annie,
you know,
I could actually play any,
when I was younger,
when I was 12,
I could have played any,
uh,
you know,
said in fucking true.
That is,
I really could have,
you know,
12 by voice to lead and changed,
uh,
this big stupid fucking,
you know,
it was in getting into metal music.
I tried to grow my hair long,
but it just,
it was too thick back in the day.
Still wish it was thick,
but we just fucking grow out into like an Afro.
I just look like an extra on like welcome back Carter,
you know,
which is fucked,
which would have been cool in the late seventies.
You know,
I miss my fucking wheel house by like,
I swear to God maybe six,
seven years if I had been born instead of 1968 if I born been born in 1962 but
then,
you know what I would have been,
I'd be 51 right now.
You know,
I would've started podcasting late in the game,
you know,
being all grumpy
radio.
Um,
anyways,
yeah.
Somebody told me a funny joke that they had in the onion.
I don't know if you guys read that,
that uh,
that periodical,
whatever the fuck you call it,
newspaper,
um,
phone news,
is that what it's called?
I don't fucking know.
But they had something,
whether it was somebody sitting in front of the laptop,
I guess with an anger,
anguish look on their face.
I haven't seen it,
but it says,
uh,
something over 250,000 podcasters stress trying to find guests for their
podcasts this week.
You know what,
that made me feel good.
That made me feel really good cause,
uh,
I don't have any guests on my fucking podcast.
Rarely do I have kissed.
And that's the fucking main reason,
cause I don't want to have to sit there and try to work with other people and
their schedules and that type of shit and fucking,
you know,
I don't want to interview my French.
So what,
what is your middle name?
I don't want to do that.
And then,
you know,
they,
they fucking book shit and then they cancel on you and then you're struggling
for a guest and then you have somebody in there and you're like,
why?
I wanted this person realized that they weren't my first choice.
You know,
speaking of which,
that reminds me,
I have to get back to Jay Moore.
I've been coming in and out on the war,
on the war,
going in and out on the road when I say the war,
because I was just reading a bunch of international shit,
I think.
And uh,
yeah,
he sent me a very flippant text message that I,
they intend on addressing,
you know,
Classic East Coast Guy.
He just can't ask you to be on the podcast.
He has to put you on the fuck at defensive,
you know,
so I'm going to call him today,
try to set up a time to do his podcast and,
and,
and we'll fucking discuss his flippant fucking text message to me,
which I did not appreciate.
All right.
See that Jay,
I'm fucking cop.
Crosspollinate near right.
Fucking guy texted me,
he's texting me.
He comes at me with this fucking tone.
Like I owe him money.
You know,
where is that fucking text message?
He,
he writes this shit like gathering,
uh,
I gathered by hearing you on other people's podcasts.
You're back in town.
Cause I told him a few weeks ago,
he said,
can you do my podcasts?
I go,
no,
I'm out of town.
And then I was,
I went over to Bert Kreischer House.
I'll give you the whole fucking soap opera because I go over it per Chrysler's
cause I'm trying to get them on our all things comedy podcast network,
right?
So I'm shooting the shit over.
I'm pitching the fucking network to Burke fracture and a,
he goes,
well this is my podcast.
Shouldn't do but fuck it.
Let's do a podcast.
So that's what happened.
So there Jay gets his tears me on Burt's.
This is what I'm guessing.
Here's me on Burt's.
And he's like,
I thought this guy said he's out of town now.
You guys fucking panties all in a Jersey bunch.
And then he sends me this fucking thing.
Well I gather you're mid town.
Let me tell you something.
Jay Morris.
Jay to the motherfucking Morris.
Okay.
I am not unready contract with you or anybody else in his podcast world.
You got to stare me.
I am afraid and I will fucking podcast with whoever the fuck I want to whenever
I want to.
Young man.
That being said,
I'm going to try to do Jay's podcast this week.
Oh,
we so sensitive.
I love you Jay Moore.
All right.
Okay.
Continuing on.
Speaking of fucking wars,
cause maybe I'll start having a war with the j Maura.
Be Good.
It'd be good for both our podcasts.
MMM.
Speaking of that Shit,
not like I've done this.
I'm just all bullshit and okay,
before you guys fucking go epic,
epic fucking uh,
something,
something Twitter,
knock out,
whatever the fuck you,
you know,
it's all I'm trying to say.
Fucking know what anything's called.
Anyways,
I was on a,
I was reading the news today as I do.
I got one of those iPad minis for my birthday.
Butoh Bodo Boto Baloo so now what I do is sit out on my front porch like a
fucking old man in a rocking chair and you know,
that's something I was fighting,
fighting how great it felt to sit on a front porch sitting on a rocking chair,
reading the 21st century's newspaper.
You know,
I don't have the paper in my hand and isn't that some little kid that comes in?
Hey Mr Right.
Throws the thing over the fucking wall and I'll,
Hey dad,
thanks.
Thanks a lot dad.
Johnny Appleseed,
right.
And I get my Nicco when he goes,
Oh,
I thank you Mr [inaudible].
He goes down at buys like fucking 80 pieces of candy like you could back in the
day,
right down to the penny arcade.
You know,
some guy down there with the fucking derby on beating you with a cane.
Um,
I was fighting that feeling
just sitting out there.
I'm telling you right now,
just fucking given to be in an old fuck.
Like making shit out on a front porch.
If you don't have one Usia neighbors,
right?
He's at work.
Fuck them.
That's his fault for having a job.
You're in between jobs.
Nobody's using his porch.
Right.
Chat the clique.
That's not even his porch.
At least the land isn't that belongs to the court.
What the fuck is the Apache?
Depending on where the hell you live.
I shot his fucking land.
What?
Cause a piece of paper says it is.
I don't fucking know.
So I'm sitting out there on,
on,
on my front porch,
on my rocking chair and I was just reading about a,
I'm trying to figure out why we are arming the rebels in Syria.
Right?
And why Russia is arming the dude in power there.
That Assad,
sad guy.
Whatever the fuck his name is.
Right.
I can't figure out,
I'm trying to figure out what both sides have to gain.
You know,
was that President Coo with us and he was given us whatever we wanted and now
he's not.
So we're like,
fuck Campbell going to help the,
the fucking rebels.
I have no idea.
I fucking,
I scoured the Internet for like at least three minutes before I did this podcast
and I could not find one fucking reason why we were doing it.
Oh,
why Russia was doing what they were doing.
Now Russia is saying that the reason why they actually gave a reason,
they said the reason why they are backing the dude in power in Syria is because
the Syrian rebels kill,
uh,
Syrian soldiers and then eat their hearts in front of the locals.
And if that doesn't sound like a bunch of bullshit,
I don't know what is.
So that's his justification.
He goes,
well,
you know,
the fucking sitting there,
I eat in the end trails like licorice,
you know,
we don't wanna be a part of that.
And uh,
but as far as I can tell,
we haven't said why we're backing them.
I Dunno,
cause they want democracy,
which is what we always say.
But then we usually,
it's,
there's something else we want there.
You know,
something in the gift shop that we got our eye on,
so I have no idea.
So I'm going to pay attention to it.
You know what I'm actually thinking,
I'm just thinking back.
This is just like a,
which is making money.
I think that that's what this meeting is about,
Northern Ireland.
Okay.
All right.
In a way,
like the u s is just like,
well listen,
we don't manufacture anything in our country,
every mall anymore.
Everything's fucking left.
You know that any luck we can fucking legalize weed will finally have some neck
sport again.
It's basically,
we're not making any fucking money.
No rush.
She's just like,
Hey,
you know,
we're fucking,
uh,
we've got a big shit storm over here too,
right?
Well,
I'm this side you want,
I'm not Saturday.
Kind of blow each other up and how we make a little more money.
What do you think?
Sound good?
All right,
let's make some funny on too.
I took a break and then they walk out.
Then that's it.
So anyway,
star,
those rich kids who run the world,
I guess they're in a northern Ah,
Ireland this week and there's no protesters.
There's like 2000 protesters.
Okay.
You know,
I don't know as much as I bitch,
I don't think I'd ever go to a protest.
It's just so much work.
You've got to make that sign.
Okay.
You know,
and I know none of the big thing is you gotta be informed.
You don't,
you know,
you're informed as a protester.
They don't show your interview on TV.
They always show the biggest fucking wing nut at those things.
You know,
half a titty out,
face fucking painted,
you know?
Hey man,
like it ain't right,
man.
No,
that fucking hatchet dude,
I don't know.
Sorry,
this podcast,
this podcast is all over the place,
but you know what?
I have been all over the place.
I had another wonderful quick tour.
I did a St Louis,
Cleveland,
Ohio,
and uh,
in Buffalo,
New York.
And um,
I got to tell you,
I spent way too little time time in each city.
I,
uh,
I had a great fucking time in each and every one of those,
those places.
Uh,
let's start with St Louis.
May Be in Saint Louis,
Louis.
Um,
okay.
I can't remember the name of the fucking place someplace.
Everything's named a pageant or the palace.
I don't fucking remember.
Then my
a website takes it off the second.
It's the day of the show.
Takes it off the thanks.
And now I don't even fucking know.
Um,
anyways,
I performing this wonderful theater that I've been to before that I'm actually
going to look up right now because the owner is so fucking cool and I'm being a
Dick Right now.
Let's see here.
Say Louis Bill Burr.
Let's see what comes up here.
Bill burr bombs in Saint Louis.
What the fuck or shit?
No.
Um,
okay.
Where the hell is it?
Oh,
there it is.
The pageant pay,
the wonderful pageant theater and right up the street there they got,
they had all the others cool old record store,
which I never got into.
They had a great pizza place and they also had,
um,
they had this fucking a,
this bowling alley slash cool bar and it was perfect.
It was just enough for the old bowling alley thing and not at,
not like a whole hipster thing with the bar.
And all it had was like fucking eight lanes wasn't one of those places that has
like 40 fucking lanes.
So me and Jason Law had went in there killing time during the day and uh,
we bowled one frame.
We were fucking horrific.
I bowled in,
I think I bowled an 87,
you know,
I ball once every five years.
By the time I figured out how to get some,
so I bought Bolis straight ball of course,
but by the time I've figured out how to fucking,
you know,
get back into that rhythm,
whatever the fuck it is that I'm doing wrong,
my fucking hacky swing there.
Uh,
I'm usually in the fucking six frame,
is that the right thing?
Had a beer.
They had a great time and I went into their,
their,
uh,
they have,
they have a city park there.
And I was thinking there's no fucking awake cause it like,
you know,
it's one of the biggest pork so it'll all be United States.
And I'm like,
well,
I've been through central park,
it's not going to be as big as that shit.
This thing was fucking huge.
Highly recommend it if you don't like going to gyms.
I like to work out outside,
just walk around and that type of thing.
And they got like a fucking golf course.
Is it Goddamn Zoo in there?
Right.
I'm walking around the outskirts all of a sudden looking at a fucking zebra.
Okay.
I think it was,
I walked the whole way around the outside.
It had to have been at least four,
four and a half,
five miles.
And uh,
okay.
It's a great time that I went bowling,
went out,
had a great show.
What do we do that night?
Oh,
then we went upstairs to the rooftop bar.
I'd like does the Blue Moon or whatever the hell it is,
the Moon Tower hotel that I was staying at at uh,
went up there,
hung out Metson people after the show,
everything was good.
And then there was these two fucking hilarious kids who are like,
uh,
like 21,
22 years,
years old,
level drunk.
You know,
this fucking dude came up because somebody had yelled something about Tim Tebow
during the show.
So it comes out to me is I uh,
I uh,
[inaudible] stuff now.
My God.
All right,
cool man.
Great.
Because I actually had a good time.
Three minutes later it comes out to me.
Ah,
that,
ah,
Yay.
Hey,
tell Jay wows staff.
I man.
Yeah,
I understand you.
You already said that.
You already said you're not driving.
Are you okay.
All right dude.
Listen,
I'm going to be over here with some friends.
I got to go.
All right.
See you sit down.
Fuck it.
Like half hour later.
Okay.
I'm coming back from taking a piss.
I come back up and he's sitting down where I was sitting.
Okay.
And he just good Cevallo Vaga is,
and uh,
he was such his buddy at this point,
he's trying to get them up out of the chair and he refuses to get up or help and
the other guys too drunk to get him out.
So it was like this fucking keystone cop shit of this dude trying to drag his
friend out of the fucking chair and we're all sitting there,
me and like four or five other people looking at them.
We finally just picked our drinks up.
We went to another table and I think it took him another 20 minutes to get them
out of the fucking chair.
Um,
I'll speak at a tip.
Tivo,
everybody
who's got the Jesus Freak.
We do.
I love all these more on football feds.
Who would think that there's going to be like a quarterback controversy?
Uh,
now that we have Tim t buff,
are you forgetting that bill Belichick is a genius.
Okay.
And don't even talk to me telling me he's a fucking cheater.
All right.
I didn't want to hear that shit.
Unless you're going to fucking take down every other goddamn coach,
including Ole Miss,
the fucking twinkle toes up there in Seattle.
Uh,
Pete Carroll.
Could you look any more honest than fucking Pete Carroll?
Right?
Other than that guy,
he looks like that fucking Mr. Green Gene Guy.
The next door,
Flanders on fucking,
uh,
the Simpsons.
He doesn't have the glasses,
but he has that vibe.
Flanders actually looks like William h Macy with John Lennon glasses.
Um,
but I'm saying Pete Carroll's Vibe is that,
but then you look at the shitty day at USC and right before the shit hit the fan
and they were going to get suspended,
he fucking takes off and goes up to Seattle.
Hey,
and what was Pete Carroll guilty of it?
USC doing everything everybody else does at that fucking level.
All right,
so all you cont who called bill Belicheck cheaters.
You're morons.
All right.
That's the way the game is played at that level.
There's millions of dollars.
There's yachts,
there's whores.
The second that shit is at stake.
Recognition,
legacy,
forget it.
All the rules are out the fucking when they're all being bent.
All right.
So anyways,
this is why the Patriots are going to,
are going,
uh,
if Tim Teebo is ever going to excel in the NFL,
it's going to be with the New England patriots and I'll bring you a one fucking
play and I'll maybe give me an email.
I'll give you a link to it.
The reason for it was,
was back with Doug Flutie was playing with us,
not Doug Flutie.
Who the fuck was it?
Who did the pooch kick?
Wait,
wait a minute.
Do I have that wrong?
Am I that old?
What was that def famous fucking play.
We're all of a sudden he fucking came in,
right?
That was with us.
Add Jesus Christ.
I'm losing my fucking mind here.
How old am I?
All right,
here we go.
Doug Flutie poach.
Kick.
Alright.
Oh,
dramatic yet.
There you go.
And he gets it.
That was,
it was with a Jesus.
How fucking long did he play?
I saw Doug Flutie when I had season tickets in 1989 when we had the little Paul
Rivera on the side of the helmet.
1980 fucking nine.
And he graduated in like 84.
Okay.
He'd already been,
oh,
that was before he went to the CFL.
He'd been with Chicago leave,
then he came with us and,
uh,
okay.
Oh Jesus.
Did I ever tell you that fucking store?
I can't believe I'm going to tell this fucking story.
MMM,
okay.
Okay.
When I came out,
what year this was,
it was when Doug Flutie was playing
okay.
With the buffalo bills.
And I remember,
you know,
that was first,
right around then he had come out and said that he had an autistic child and he
had,
he had the Flutie flakes that was to raise money for autism.
This great thing.
Right.
And,
uh,
so we're in the stands was sitting in the end zone.
It's me,
Bobby Kelly,
and this buddy of mine.
Okay.
Uh,
one of my old drinking buddies from back in the day.
This is the guy I told you.
You got,
he got into the handshake fight with the Elvis impersonator.
Yeah.
I would tell you that one.
We were in,
daisy Buchanan's a famous meat market on Newbury Street in Boston.
Right.
And,
uh,
you know,
everybody's in their hammered,
right?
Everybody's listening to music and we'll fucking whatever.
It's the middle of the fucking night.
So basically every guy in there is probably 50 to 60% on their way to either
getting laid or going home and jerk and off after a slice of pizza.
That's right where the night is.
But everybody still has hope that they're going to be one of the guys that gets
fucking laid.
All right,
everything's going good.
Music is playing and all that shit.
All of a sudden,
the entire,
you just feel this energy towards the door.
Like what the fuck's going on?
You could feel this commotion.
So we fucking look over and there's this guy dressed up as Elvis for no fucking
apparent reason.
It's like the middle of the summer,
you know,
it wasn't the anniversary of his,
of his death.
I don't,
you know,
we weren't Vegas.
I just fucking guy walks in dressed like Elvis.
So all the whole energy of the fucking bar goes over there and every fucking
chicken there wants to go over and get their picture with the guy.
So this dude basically cock blocks the whole fucking bar.
Even half the guys are laughing cause he's doing all the karate moves and shit.
It was ridiculous.
It was funny.
But also it was very passive aggressive cause all the pussy went up to him.
So,
and half the fucking guys.
So my buddy,
I was pissed.
I didn't realize he was pissed at them.
So everybody's lining up shaking hands with this Elvis impersonator trying to
get their picture with them and blah blah blah,
blah blah.
So my buddy comes up to him,
he comes up to last and he's fucking,
he starts shaking his hand.
And when my buddy worked before he was going to get into a fight,
I don't know why he would always be like looking up in the air.
Like,
what's up dude?
What's going on?
Huh?
Rarely,
rarely dude.
And he'd be like looking like straight up in the air,
which of course he always ended up getting suckered,
but he was a big guy.
So he's usually been able to make a comeback.
So he comes walking up to this Elvis impersonator and he starts shaking his hand
and he's looking up.
In the end,
the guy's sitting there going,
well,
salt my uncle soap,
or you do,
man,
we're trying to be Elvis.
And he goes,
and he's like,
what's my buddy's like?
What's up dude?
He goes,
hey,
he's still shaking his hand.
He goes,
he goes,
why can't you just be yourself?
Right?
And immediately the Elvis guy is trying to let go of my buddy's head and he
won't let them go.
So now there's kind of squeezing each other's hand.
The guy's going to,
come on,
man,
let's go.
I got rings.
Oh Man.
Eh,
by buddy just keeps holding his hand.
He goes,
you know,
he goes,
I like Roger Clemens,
because I like the red sox.
You don't see me come in here dressed like Roger Clemens right now.
This shake could fucking hands right in this squeeze.
And now he's looking at this dude right through his stupid gold frame glasses.
And the guys going,
all right,
he drops the Elvis Shit gone.
All right,
let go of my hand.
And I'm fucking sitting there going,
oh my God,
I'm going to watch my buddy fight a fucking Elvis impersonator.
This is going to be the greatest thing ever.
And right then the fucking bouncer steps in like,
you know,
when you're watching a hockey game,
you like,
finally these two guys are going to fight and then the fucking raft comes in and
breaks it up and the whole crowd boos,
that's basically what happens.
All right?
So that's the background on this guy.
So we're at this game.
He's a big guy.
He's not the most quick way to Guy Doug Flutie has now come back.
You know,
he would play for the Boston College.
He played for the,
you know,
bears than the New England patriots.
So He's,
he's one of our guys,
but now he's playing for the buffalo bills.
The game we're going to,
this is now,
I dunno,
like the fucking,
uh,
like 97,
98 or something.
And um,
I think Pete Carroll was coaching Jesus built,
get to this story.
All right,
so every so fluid,
he's warming up in the end zone.
I have now.
Everybody's given Flutie shit even though he's our guide,
but he's piece playing for the other guys now.
So it's like some Johnny Damon Shit,
even though it wasn't his fault.
But you know,
Boston sports fans were assholes.
So everybody's given Flutie shit.
They yell at gay killed a Midget,
a floaty,
get to short all these short jokes or whatever.
So my buddy wants to get one in,
all right?
And we have end zone seats.
So we are sitting with a bunch of fucking animals.
So everybody's killed imaginary Flutie a too short or not today.
Douggie you know,
go back to Canada.
You stake,
right?
Everybody giving him shit.
And then my buddy,
he wants to be part of it.
He chimes in,
he kind of stuttered.
He just goes,
he goes,
hey,
hey floatie,
I hope your kid dies,
dude.
The whole section just goes Ugh,
and just sits down.
It was one that was one of the most fucking evil things.
But you've got to understand why.
It was funny to me was just because I knew,
I knew my buddy and I know how fucking dumb he is.
And I know that he just wanted to be a part of it.
He's just one of those guys who doesn't know where the line is.
You know those guys,
we just go,
hey,
you know,
you start making fun of this shirt.
And they go,
yeah,
at least by mother doesn't have breast cancer.
And you're like,
Jesus Christ,
how the fuck do you go from a shirt to breast cancer?
That's basically what he did.
And uh,
I remember what's his,
Bobby Kelly was absolutely fucking SPI was speechless.
Fuck,
this is one of the few times I've ever seen Bobby is every bit as twisted as I
am.
I,
I'll never forget that he was fucking,
oh,
wait a minute.
What am I talking about?
I've told this story so many times I wasn't,
I was sitting up a section over Jesus Christ.
Jesus Christ.
I've told this story so many times.
I've forgotten.
No,
he was sitting there over there.
I was,
I was the next section over.
That's right.
And then Bobby came up to me at the end of the game and told me it.
So wait.
So who else was fucking over there?
I can't remember even.
How the fuck are you?
Well,
how did you even get on the fucking story?
Oh,
Flutie that's right.
Cheating.
Okay,
let's work our way back.
Bill.
Work your way back.
I Dunno.
Is it time to do some fucking habit?
Yeah.
25 minutes in.
Here we go.
A little bit of advertising this week,
everybody.
Just a little bit,
a little bit of advertising.
Where the fuck is it?
All right.
Who's up first?
Oh,
Hulu plus everybody.
I just dreamy hit shows on your PC,
on hulu.com.
Um,
now it's time to start your free trial of exclusive content in your living room
and on your mobile devices,
on Hulu plus with Hulu plus,
you get control to watch thousands of shows wherever you want,
whenever you want.
Use Hulu plus on connected TV's,
game consoles,
Blu ray players,
Roku,
apple TV,
PC,
or watch from anywhere on your smart phone or tablet on demand at all times.
And with Hulu plus you can binge on full seasons.
What's your favorite current shows?
And even full series runs of classic TV shows.
It's endless.
Uh,
they've got community,
modern family,
southpark,
SNL,
Jimmy Kimmel,
family guy and more,
nothing but top shelf.
All the shows you want to see.
They got 'em in their catalog.
Hulu plus is only seven 99 per month,
but right now they're offering an extended free trial of Hulu plus that is only
available podcast listeners.
Take control of your TV watching experience.
Go to the podcast page on billboard.com com and Click on Hulu plus banner for
your extended free trial or go to Hulu plus.com/bill again,
the Hulu plus banner on the podcast page at [inaudible] dot com or go to Hulu
plus.com/built and eve voice everyone.
He voices.
The reason you're going to make more money in 2013th unless you some gold dig
and horror and you plan on divorcing your rich husband.
Okay,
but for the rest of us,
common people evil,
this is the reason that we're going to make more money in 2013 when your
customers call and you have your own toll free number,
professional greeting,
dial by name directory and more.
Is that a sentence that's like a fragment.
Oh,
when your customers call,
you'll have your own toll free number,
professional grading,
dial by name directory in more.
Sorry,
that's on me.
Uh,
you'll sound like a fortune 500 company and blow away your competitors.
Eve Voice lets you give out one number that rings wherever you are.
The beach,
the bar doesn't matter.
You'll sound like you're at the office.
So this is a great way to start a business while you're still at somebody else's
work and for somebody else,
you know what I mean?
We get it.
Bill,
finish the copy.
Okay.
You gotta go to [inaudible] Dot Com and use the Promo Code Bill.
He voice even takes all your evil,
all your voicemails transcribes them and sends them during instantly to you as a
text or email.
So you can check your voicemails before the meeting ends and not even look rude.
Ie voice is only 10 bucks a month right now.
Listeners to my podcast can get a free trial of ee voice for 30 days.
Stop what you're doing.
Hit Pause,
set up your eve voiced free trial and see what I'm talking about.
It's a great way to support my podcast and an easy way to make more money this
year.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com Promo Code Bill.
That's [inaudible] dot com Promo Code Bill.
Or just go to the podcast page on bill bird.com and click the voice banner ad
right now.
Okay.
So have you been,
what have you been watching you been watching spurs?
He,
he'd been watching a Bruins Blackhawks.
Either way.
Couple of amazing series.
I've blew it yesterday.
I was traveling,
so I missed the San Antonio game.
Obviously thrilled that San Antonio is up three games to two going back to
Miami.
You know,
now you know me,
I love the Celtics and anybody who plays the Lakers,
but um,
there's just a douchebag factor to people down in Miami.
We're,
let's all go to the game and where,
why,
you know,
and of course it's white.
You know that white white is the,
um,
hang on a second.
We know what it is like the,
that's the color that people who want to flaunt that they're rich.
Where if he noticed that,
like whenever they do like those,
uh,
those real housewives stories,
they always have some ridiculously expensive car.
And it's always,
it's always like,
like,
like Pearl White.
I don't know what it is about that.
They love it.
Oh,
out here in,
uh,
in La,
all the grownup up he fucking people,
they fucking all have those white cars.
I don't know why.
So when I look at those people down in Miami,
it's the same fucking thing,
you know?
What are you showing off your Tan lines?
Even when you're in the car?
I don't understand it.
Where I come from.
You know,
you get a ute,
a black car,
you know,
some gangster look at thing,
he gets some tinted windows on it.
I don't fucking know.
Although I got to tell you,
I was a big fan of milk trucks back in the day and those are always white.
This podcast is just,
what the fuck am I talking about?
So I'm rooting for,
I'm rooting for San Antonio.
I really,
you got to go for the underdog here.
You know,
the big fundamental,
the guy cheated on their chick from that fucking show,
right?
The other guy there,
the a bald guy,
Tony Coote coach at,
Oh fuck.
I don't watch hoop.
I Dunno what's going on.
Um,
why don't you stick with what you've been watching,
Bruins,
Blackhawks,
everybody.
Uh,
right now if you haven't been watching the series is tied one game to one.
Both went into overtime.
The first one went into triple overtime and uh,
two nights ago it was an overtime when for the Bruins.
And it was kind of weird cause I felt like the Bruins should've won the first
one in the hot shit one.
The second one,
although I missed most of the,
uh,
most of the second game cause I was performing in a buffalo.
But uh,
it's a classic man and the Black Hawks that they like the Bros,
man,
they're a fucking hockey team.
You know,
they got their tough guys.
I'd say they have more superstars with Hosa and Patrick Kane.
But,
um,
they got their past and then they got their grind is man,
they were fucking hockey team.
And,
um,
I really invite,
you know,
I dunno,
I really liked the way they're playing.
No filthy shit.
You know,
I don't get mad at those,
those guys who,
you know,
just doing shit to try to get an edge,
but nobody's out there trying to hurt anybody and that fucking crap.
Um,
it's just been two great games and they play again tonight.
Pivotal fucking game.
They have little fucking game.
Um,
so we'll see.
We'll see how the Bruins come out.
I heard they came out real sluggish and game two in the first period and came
out hitting in a second.
Um,
like I said,
I only came out after my show.
I saw halfway,
the last half of the third period and then into the overtime.
But um,
I watched every second of that first one.
Um,
and I was,
oh,
it was trying to stay in shape and I was on the road.
So I watched the first three periods and then the first two overtimes I was on
the elliptical.
I basically,
I stayed on the elliptical until there was an intermission.
And then in the intermission I did pushups and dips.
And then coming out of the intermission,
I did the whole fucking did the elliptical again for the next period.
I was actually thinking like,
that's how you should be watching sports instead of sitting there eating fucking
Nachos and drinking beer.
Right.
Um,
but,
uh,
I dunno when are you good until I got to tell you the Blackhawks fucking goalie
man is unbelievable.
And the exact way Pie Aa scored is,
I think what we have to do.
The second it hits you stick,
just put it on net.
Because if that guy gets a chance to square up on you,
he,
he's just stopping everything.
The goal tending is top notch,
original six.
That's all I'm going to say.
I really don't have anything bad to say about any of the Blackhawks.
I fucking like all of them.
And uh,
I'm hoping it goes seven and I obviously hope that we win,
but,
uh,
they were a great fucking team.
So tune in and check it out.
All right,
let's get to the,
uh,
let's get to the fucking,
um,
the,
the God damn,
uh,
whatever questions for the week.
Uh,
uh,
Billy red face tour.
Uh,
William,
I used to live in North Dakota and I've been to northern cities on your tour.
If you are planning to drive between gigs,
the country is beautiful,
but the distances are immense.
Wrap your brain around long drives six to eight hours depending on how fast you
drive.
Uh,
I now live in Chicago.
Black Hawks.
Yeah,
dude,
you got to understand,
I've been doing the road hardcore since the late nineties,
so you know,
I could do six hour drives in my sleep,
but I'm also,
I'm taking a bus so it's not going to be a problem.
But,
um,
I'm also beyond excited to do this tour because I have performed in Boise.
I never did the comedy club,
but I did do a college up there.
It wasn't Boise state was something else.
Um,
so I've,
I drove her around a little bit,
but I've never been to Montana and I'm basically going to drive across that
whole state.
I have done,
I've done like Sioux Falls,
South Dakota,
and I've done like Fargo,
North Dakota,
but I've never been to the western part of the state,
so I'm going to be loving life,
um,
when I'm out there.
So I want to see they'll all those cool looking ranches.
I want to see a couple of bison.
I want to see the fucking billboard with before and after pictures about people
on meth.
You know what I mean?
That's like a major fucking problem.
Like I bet you nobody,
I bet the walking dead gets really low ratings out in Montana just because if
they just,
all they need to do is look out the fucking window,
right to see that.
I'm googling right now.
Montana meth problem.
They get meth project,
documentary highlights,
Montana's meth problem.
NPR.
NPR was up there.
Yes.
Montana has a meth problem.
Measuring meth in Montana.
Montana.
Meth project news about the Montana meth project.
I said they've got a project going on.
Let's read this one here.
Yes,
Montana has a meth problem.
Do you guys really want to hear me read out loud?
You probably don't.
Uh,
I heard that Utah,
Colorado have a symbolist situation,
but I don't know who is the leader.
Um,
I get tired of arguing the point,
but the facts don't support your post.
I'm not going to present evidence because it's clear.
It would not matter.
I guess he's defending Montana.
I don't fucking know.
It's going to be a great time.
Oh,
you know what?
I never finished talking about that tour that I just did the uh,
I went to Cleveland,
Ohio.
All right.
Had a great time.
One of my favorite people in this business,
nick costs this,
owns,
uh,
Pickwick and frolic slash the hilarides comedy club.
And that's where I played from 2004 right on up.
He used to headline me when I could only draw half the fucking room and a half
of those people would just go in there.
Cause Nick had such a great restaurant upstairs and the Martini bar and
everything.
Um,
and when nick bought in to that part of the,
uh,
the city,
you know,
there was nobody there like I,
it was just crap.
You got to go in there.
It's like a five star restaurant.
They got a live show with these,
these dancing girls downstairs in a Martini bar.
And then he has this beautiful showroom with a balcony.
It's,
it's absolutely gorgeous place.
And um,
so he built this thing when they would,
when Cleveland was just after 5:00 PM became a ghost town and you'd be in there,
you felt like you were on the fucking titanic except it never sank.
Right.
You're just on this luxury liner.
There was,
he didn't have to leave.
You ate,
you had this great meal,
you did your show and then when you walked out,
there was all these beautiful women in this Martini bar was the self sustaining
unit,
this fucking oasis.
But the second,
the night ended,
the cop would literally escort me out of the place and would walk me over to my
hotel so I wouldn't get clubbed over the head by a piece of pipe that was
probably laying right in the street.
And uh,
he was the only game in town,
especially on the block that he was on.
And he was kind of like a third of the way up the block.
So he's really hidden and he was having a rough go of trying to get the thing
going.
And uh,
over the years I watched like the House of Blues opened up across the street,
blah,
blah.
Fast forward to now,
nine years later,
you know,
I'm in town,
I'm doing this theater right down the street and I'm like,
I got to go see next.
So I go over there to go get some dinner before the show and I'm coming up the
street and it's just a mob scene.
It's just like outdoor,
everybody's outdoor cafes is this guy playing acoustic guitar,
like hired by this restaurant,
house of Blues is this line up the street.
Um,
he's just the greatest fucking guy.
So I went over there,
I had dinner and then I went,
uh,
I did my show,
I had a great time,
you know,
went out,
took pictures,
signed DVDs and all that shit.
And then we had the after party over at his Martini bar cause I wanted to drive
some business his way and I want to thank everybody.
Seriously,
man,
there's no bullshit.
Everybody came over there.
If you spent $1 over there,
that's one of my great friends,
uh,
in business and in life.
So I really appreciate it.
And if you ever seriously in the Cleveland area,
you want to see a great show,
just have a great meal.
Go down to the,
uh,
the Pickwick and frolic romantic guys the best and it cost to sale.
Tell him I said what's up?
So anyways,
back to the,
uh,
back to the reeds here.
When the fuck are they?
And the worst.
All right,
no subject on this one.
Bill.
Your problem with Christianity is that you are in the wrong church.
Just switch over to the episcopal episcopal or Lutheran or something and get
baptized and all of a sudden you'll receive the Holy Spirit,
which will bring you to a higher spiritual level with a literal connection to
God.
Uh,
all right.
You know something,
I'm sure every religion has.
It's a,
has something to offer.
You know what it is about episcopal or Lutheran is I'm lazy.
I already know you can't teach an old dog new tricks.
Okay.
I know the prayers and I know the songs from my fucking,
this would be like me moving to La and not being a Celtics fan anymore and
switching over to the clippers,
you know,
not saying you bought the clippers are actually decent now,
so I can't,
I'm not really insulting you,
but uh,
yeah.
Tell me some more about the episcopal in our Lutheran thing.
Cause I actually always enjoyed going to church as far as,
I felt like it was a reset thing every week to remind yourself not to be a
complete hunk of shit or at least try not to be for as long as you could until
the next mass.
But I just never liked all the other crap that was involved in it.
Um,
but as far as me receiving the Holy Spirit,
which will bring me to a higher spiritual level and a little connection to God,
like I can really do that on my own,
you know,
if I want it to,
if I really,
if I wasn't such a piece of shit,
if I really just,
I,
you don't really need to go down there and do all the old law Selema that's all
just,
you know,
rituals and I blessed the water and I throw it in your face and now the evil
spirits or out of years,
but it's complete horse shit.
You could splash me with as much holy water as you want to.
If I don't give a fuck and I want to go out and just do stuff,
the water is not going to like fix me,
you know?
Oh,
bill stopped being a cunt swing by,
you know what?
I'm going to go to one.
I go to Lutheran.
Episcopals too hard to say.
Um,
I dunno man.
I get weirded out when I go in those fucking places and then behave and he
showed up in everybody grab hands.
It just makes me feel all douchey.
Um,
all right.
Freedom built.
Please don't talk about freedom when you are over there.
Over where?
Well,
why don't you fucking,
I'll,
okay,
here we go.
This guy's gonna Trash America,
right bill,
please don't talk about freedom.
When you people over there don't have the freedom to decide whether you want
half your dick cut off or not.
The way women in Africa don't have the freedom decide whether they want half
their vagina cutoff or not.
They don't cut off their vagina.
You ignorant dump Twat.
All you American country Americans do is talk about freedom because you have
none.
Um,
you know what sir?
You sound as ignorant as what you're making fun of.
So congratulations.
Welcome to the quad,
sir.
When did I talk about freedom?
I don't even remember talking about that,
sir.
You know,
half the Shit I talk about.
I'm just trying to fill up an hour here.
All right,
Americans,
was that your best one?
Did you have a list?
Can he come up with something a little bit better?
You know,
Americans,
you're trashing all the Americas,
so you basically trashing this whole half of the half of the,
uh,
the world.
You do realize that these are the Americas,
North America and South America.
All right?
And you're calling me a dumb [inaudible].
They don't,
they don't fucking cut off half the vagina.
They remove the clitoris there.
You know,
how exactly do they do that?
I don't even want to know.
It's fucking disgusting.
Um,
well what is he talking about?
Aren't the guy every week.
I'm talking about bankers.
How they got everybody by the balls sturdy.
You listened to this thing.
All right,
we're just going to move on.
You know what you are.
You're basically,
that was the,
uh,
the email version of that guy who kept saying Tivo to me.
All right,
my car is shit.
Hey billion.
I'm a high school student in Arkansas.
Razorbacks sec and my car is pure shit.
The pain is blotchy.
Do this isn't pimp my ride.
What are you think I'm going to do?
Fucking get over there and have somebody come in a
put a flat screen TV and your trunk.
Uh,
the paint is blotchy and fading.
The interior is shit.
The air conditioner doesn't work and there's a ton of stickers on the back from
the previous owner.
It's actually embarrassing anytime a person,
especially girls see it.
So how do I get over my shitty car?
Also,
your podcast has not only helped me relieve the stress from school,
but it gets me through class if I'm having a slow day.
All right?
What you got to do is you have to embrace your shitty car,
you know,
takes a certain swagger to drive a shitty car.
You've got to have a sense of humor about it.
You know,
if somebody trashes your car,
just uh,
just,
you know,
you can do one or two things.
Either agree with them or just be like,
how dare you?
How dare you trashed at that.
Right.
There was a classic,
that's an original condition.
All right?
Or whatever the F I don't know what the fuck to do.
You can take the bumper stickers off.
You know what?
You could throw some rims on it.
Fuck that.
Don't don't put rims on a piece of shit car.
This is the biggest thing that I would say.
All right.
If you're trying to get a lady
right,
you're in college,
everybody understands you're going to be broke.
What I would do,
you got to make sure the inside of the car is clean.
Spend some money,
get that fucker steam cleaned and get some fucking air fresheners.
So it's,
it's,
it smells.
All right.
You could probably take off the bumper sticker.
You can get a $99 fucking paint job every fucking state you go to.
There's some content on TV talking about a $99 paint job,
you know,
pick a dark color,
that usually will,
uh,
I dunno,
maybe paint over the other shit.
Well,
I don't know much about paint.
I have no idea.
Maybe you'll be all right.
What kind of car is it,
sir?
If you could help me out with what kind of car you have,
uh,
maybe I can help you out.
I Dunno.
Listen,
I drove in 83 Ford Ranger two wheel drive,
five speed amfm fucking radio.
It just was a mess.
And I finally put a nice stereo in there and somebody smashed the window,
ripped up the fucking plastic like dashboard and yanked the radio out.
And I didn't have room for another one that had this gaping fucking hole with
wires hanging out and uh,
and I wasn't getting any pussy.
There you go,
sir.
You know what,
I've come around to your side.
I see what the problem is.
Uh,
you know what?
I would go to campus parties and try to go back to her dorm room.
Just avoid the whole car thing,
the whole car situation or you know something.
If you meet a girl that you really liked,
just admit to it and just say,
listen,
I gotta I gotta tell you something before we go to my car.
My car is,
it's a mess and it's really embarrassing.
I'm really self conscious about it,
but blog just own up to it.
Girls love that because then that kicks into the motherly thing.
They go,
oh,
that's okay.
I don't think it's that pad.
And next thing you know that blowing.
Yeah.
So they just make sure it smells okay.
That's the biggest thing about women.
When you're younger and you don't have any fucking money,
if he just make a fucking effort,
you know,
have you fight.
If you're going out,
just make sure in case you get lucky cleanup you fucking room.
Don't have dirty laundry laying all over the place.
Make the fucking bed,
get a couple of scented candles,
all that Hacky Shit,
you know,
and for the love of God when you get in there,
do not have overhead lighting.
There's nothing women hate more than fucking overhead.
Lighting as a middle aged guys like me is you're balding.
You really start to hate overhead lighting,
but
well,
you know women,
they fucking hate overhead lighting.
All right,
self.
You have overhead lighting.
Go out and buy.
Invest in a fucking,
just a,
just a fucking bedside reading lamp or whatever and then buy some cool fucking,
I know this is how I keep,
but just call some cool fabric.
If you can throw it over the top,
gives it more of a fucking Softlight little mood.
Next,
he know a Teddy's around.
You got some skills,
you know,
you fucking rounded second and the rest is on you.
Okay.
There you go.
All right.
The royal family.
Everybody.
Um,
this one says,
Bill,
I'm curious about your feelings on the royal.
Oh wait,
I got it back up.
I remember the first time I brought a girl back when I was in New York and I
didn't,
I didn't have shit.
I had my fucking couch when my dad's dental office in the early seventies floral
pattern made out of wood debt.
Like I swear to God,
you could fucking kill a village.
You could club people to death with this couches.
Like it,
it took like three people to bring it in.
Um,
okay.
And all I had was the,
Oh,
I had overhead lighting.
I had a light bulb would nothing even covering that.
And I had this old fixture that you'd turn it on.
It would make this like you slapped somebody in the face when you turned it,
when you turned it on.
And,
uh,
we were just sitting there and like,
I can't,
it was like we was sitting next to the sun and that was when I first learned
about overhead lighting and
you know,
I made my move and everything and I was like two minutes.
And she,
she was just like,
all right,
wait,
wait.
Can we just like,
just wait a second?
And she goes,
I need to fix something.
And she went in and I had my bedroom door was open.
What she did was she turned on the light in there that was also overhead
lighting,
but it was another rumble way.
And then she went and she turned off the light in the living room.
And guess what I did the next day I went out and I bought a fucking lamp.
There you go.
That's my limp story.
Everybody.
Okay.
Uh,
the Royal Family Bill A,
I'm curious about your feelings on the royal family and the Brits occupation of
Northern Ireland.
Looking forward to seeing you in September at the Chicago theater.
Go hawks a Bruins.
Remind me of a bunch of Prince Charles is on skates and now they don't,
you know,
I really hate when fucking people,
like those are two great fucking games and then your team wins and then you
texted me bro,
and suck or suck it,
you know,
those fucking morons.
That's why,
you know,
I've kind of stopped tweeting about sports on my Twitter page because it
literally,
it was turning into the exact reason why I don't go to a sports bar because of
all just the fee all day,
all day,
you know,
that type of shit.
And it's always the most unathletic fucking moron.
Can't even talk about the game.
Just complete shit head.
So,
uh,
I dunno,
I've kind of toned down the Twitter,
the Twitter in there.
Um,
my feelings on the royal family and the Brits occupation of Northeast Ireland
now obviously I don't think they should be,
it's not that fucking place.
You know,
I actually learned all that shit about the whiskey.
Now I've been drinking Jamison this whole fucking time,
which I guess is from Northern Ireland.
So I guess that's the sellout whiskey.
If you're in Ireland and you supposed to be drinking powers,
but I can't find powers anywhere.
Okay.
Jamison is marker did really well.
That's like the Pepsi,
a Whiskey I guess.
Um,
I don't fucking though.
Should they be there?
I don't.
I don't think so.
I don't understand why they haven't left yet.
They've left pretty much everywhere else.
They got beaten back pretty much everywhere else.
India,
Hong Kong,
Rwanda,
the United States of America.
They've been beaten back.
Falkland Islands.
They held on to that one.
You know what they like?
They like,
uh,
the royal family's like tiger woods after his divorce,
you know,
lost a ton of shit,
but still as money,
you know.
Other than that,
I don't mind them.
I don't mind that,
that Prince Guy,
whatever his fucking name is the blond guy.
Okay.
Harry Harry looks like a cunt though.
He does.
He's got that.
He's got bully face.
I don't know if it's cause all those freckles or whatever,
but he just looks like the kind of kid that would just fucking punch you in the
side of the head for no reason.
Uh,
is all the brother looks a little soft though,
you know,
probably artistic.
I don't know shit about them to be honest with you.
You guys seem to like him.
So God,
God bless you.
Continue.
Continue to pay attention to them.
Are they like your Kennedy's and the,
there's so much inner fucking breeding going on that they all kind of have the
same face.
Just like the Kennedy's Kennedys.
All easy as you see the fucking teeth on that family.
Uh,
okay.
Lost it to a famous guy.
Bill.
My name is Jessica.
Holy Shit.
I'll
finally writes in.
I'm 20 and I live in Miami.
Great.
I've already trashed Miami here.
Okay.
So about a year ago I was vacationing in D R is that Dominican Republic?
Uh,
I dunno.
And I met a famous person and ended up sleeping with him.
Dominican Republic.
I'm going to guess it was a baseball player.
Did you fuck Sammy Sosa?
Um,
he goes,
he's not very famous in the u s Oh,
okay.
Only in Latin America.
All right.
Ricky Martin's gay.
Okay.
Uh,
oh.
Is that one of those,
is that the guy that j Lo is married to?
I don't fucking know.
All right,
let's,
let's plow ahead here.
Point of this story.
Stories that ever since that night we've kept in touch and I've already seen him
three times since then.
It is really interesting.
She goes,
I've seen him every time he comes to Miami.
Is this great be like a hot chick you can like bang famous fucking people,
you know,
and just not just be like working at Kinko's,
but you're hot and you can like bang somebody that you saw in a movie,
you know,
as a guy,
he just,
we just don't have that option.
You know?
Good looking guy.
You work in a Kentucky Fried Chicken.
The he think you're going to Bang Olivia Wilde that I don't think so.
Um,
the last time I saw him was this past April.
We usually go out to clubs while he's here and I've even met some of his famous
friends.
I'm just a regular girl.
So you can imagine how infatuated I am with this guy.
I am infatuated with this story.
Um,
she goes,
he's the only person I've ever slept with.
So you could imagine the amount of emotion I've invested in this.
Please tell me you made a music condom with his around the world.
Dick,
sorry,
not trying to ruin the romance there.
Just run a little bit of reality.
Um,
I've always get,
I always get sad because I know that things are probably not going to work out
in my favor besides the fact that he is famous.
He also lives in a different country than me.
He's 10 years older than me and has a child.
Well,
that's game set.
Match,
right?
This sweetheart,
I think you've got to protect your heart and uh,
either put him in a place mentally where you're not going to develop feelings
and when it comes to town,
you get to have a fun time.
Um,
but other than that,
when he leaves,
I would try and find somebody,
you know,
that at least lives in this hemisphere.
I don't know,
but h your life.
All right.
He goes,
I have hoped that her relationship,
she goes,
I hope that our relationship could happen because I've been lucky enough to have
so much
to have.
So much has happened already.
In addition,
he has plans to move to Miami soon.
We talk once a month or every couple of weeks through text.
Well listen,
he might just be stringing you along.
MMM.
So I would be like,
look,
I'm starting to develop feelings for ea and uh,
you know,
I kinda got to cut it off here to protect myself,
but if you move to Miami then we can pick up where we left off.
Sound good?
All.
Ah,
all right.
That's all as Hillel,
right?
Whatever she,
she goes,
we talk once a month or every couple of weeks through text.
Only thing is I'm usually the one that takes the initiative to text him or see
him while he's here,
which really bugs me a,
yeah.
You know what?
I can't,
I don't even need to read the rest of this.
I'll blow through the rest of that same time.
He always shows interest in me and when we spend time together,
remembers everything.
Yeah.
You might just be his woman in that,
in that town.
I hate to tell you,
she goes,
should I hope for relationship with this guy given everything that's happened
already?
No,
you shouldn't.
Should I stop talking to him since I am the one that takes the initiative most
of the time?
Or should I be content with the situation?
Uh,
yeah,
he's stringing you along.
He's stringing you along.
Um,
I don't think he's a bad guy,
but yours is a,
your his woman in Miami.
So,
um,
sounds like you want more than that.
So
as much as this glamorous life is interesting to you,
in the end,
it sounds like you're going to get hurt.
If I had to guess,
if I had to guess,
it sounds like you're going to get hurt.
So I would,
uh,
I would just add that,
you know,
just stop texting the guy,
that's what I would do.
Just stop texting him and just be like,
hey,
you know,
when you,
when your shiny watch come back to Miami,
if I'm not in a relationship,
but you want to hang out down at the ground,
Rod,
let's,
uh,
let's fucking do it.
But other than that,
you know what,
don't you fucking
enjoy the world and the pussy that it has to offer.
Right?
I'm sorry,
I might've been a little crass here,
but that's basically,
that's basically the situation.
All right.
We had a long,
I've,
I've tried the long distance relationship thing.
It didn't end up working out.
Uh,
you know,
I dunno.
So anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
Everybody,
I'll,
how far into the Sam?
I have 55 minutes.
55 minutes.
All right,
well before I go,
I want to thank everybody who came out to all my shows in a,
out there in buffalo of do,
I didn't even talk about Buffalo.
I played this a,
the symphony hall.
Beautiful,
beautiful symphony hall,
unbelievable crowd and all of that.
And,
um,
I had a lot of people from Toronto came over asking me when I'm going to be in
Canada.
And the answer to that is,
I hate to say it's going to be next March.
I know,
I know what the fuck I,
it was supposed to be this summer,
but I dunno,
we just felt like the summertime,
it's always snowing up there.
You can finally go outside.
Why are you going to sit inside and watch some red cunt like me on stage?
We can go out and go water skiing or whatever the fuck it is you do up there.
So,
and also just figured I'd have a better chance on getting on some radio stations
if it was hockey season,
be another angle to sell him a,
a comedian first time touring Canada.
He's a big hockey fan,
Bruins fan.
He can come in and hang with you.
When he told Talk Sports,
sort of a marketing thing.
I was pushing for January and then we got worried about flights with the snow
and all this shit up there.
And uh,
I know you're like,
what the fuck?
But you can't run a string of dates together flying into the middle of a
shitstorm cause you'll end up missing a date.
And I don't want to deal with that.
So we've decided on,
on March,
I'm going to hit all the hockey cities and possibly a couple of more depending
on how tickets sales go.
And I'm going to start doing these like more of these mini tours,
like the red face tour.
By the way,
tickets are selling,
they're selling like hot cakes.
So,
uh,
what do I got here?
Coming up?
Uh,
yeah,
the 28th through August 3rd.
Yeah.
No,
it's not 28,
27,
26,
July 26 through August 3rd.
Uh,
for those of you haven't been listened this past week,
I'm going to be hitting,
doing shows in the states of Idaho,
Montana,
South Dakota,
Kansas,
Colorado,
western Texas.
And uh,
I got a private show and a New Mexico.
So,
um,
I got that whole tour set up.
I'm working on a European tour and so far I know we got London,
we got something in Scotland and Amsterdam and I imagine I'm going to do all the
Scandinavian countries.
Okay.
And then probably all the way over and to Helsinki do,
I'll do Ireland.
I'm hoping to do Ireland,
Scotland,
uh,
England,
Amsterdam,
and then hit Copenhagen,
Oslo,
Stockholm and Helsinki.
Um,
that's what I would love to do.
And then,
I dunno,
I mean they're going to go after I do all that and I make some money or
whatever.
I'm going to fucking either go down to Italy and eat like a fucking pig or I'm
going to go to Paris,
uh,
go over to France.
I wanted to go to like Francis something like,
cause I,
I took French.
Okay.
I tried French for a long time when I was in a high school and I was always into
the Tour de France.
I'd always watch the tennis Roland Garros.
Um,
I dunno,
I was a big World War II buffs there for a minute.
Okay.
And then,
you know,
all the d day stuff,
there's so much,
there's so much that I want to see in France alone.
You know,
I want to see the beaches of Normandy.
I want to go to the memorial cemetery.
I want to go to the French Open.
I want to go to the Tour de France.
I want to go to Paris.
You know,
I want to ride a bike in Paris.
Why not write,
edit twinkle toes,
put on a fucking baret big loaf of French bread coming out of my backpack.
You know,
wearing those pants that don't fit down on my fucking ankles and a striped shirt
on.
Grow a little stupid mustache.
Why not right then I want to go over to fuck in,
uh,
Italy.
These are all dreams of mine.
I want to go to Italy and I want to somehow learn enough Italian and start
people over there arguing about who makes the better,
whatever the dishes,
and then let me be the judge.
And then I sit there and eat like a fucking king.
I want to do that.
I want to go to Belgium and drink some booze.
I ran into somebody on the road,
told me they got trapped over in Belgium one time because it was snowing and I,
and they just sat there drinking beer all night and uh,
stepping outside every once in a while,
just look into this beautiful snow in the city and I literally could see it and
I was just like,
I want to fucking do that.
So,
um,
I don't know.
Trying to expand the horizons yet,
people.
And next year,
so next year I got the Canadian tour and then also I'm going to try and do a
tour of,
I'm gonna try to tour all of Australia,
which would be Perth all the way to a home,
a bond.
Scott,
I got to go see his grave site,
you know,
pay my respects and go all the way through.
I don't know,
all the way back.
Work my way all the way back to Sydney and maybe have time to check out the
great barrier reef.
See,
that's what I want to do.
That's the game plan for me.
All right.
And if the Bruins can win the Stanley Cup over the next fucking six,
seven days,
it would just be a perfect God damn year.
All right.
So anyways,
that is the podcast this week.
Everybody,
once again,
thank you to everyone who came out and,
uh,
and Buffalo,
oh,
I keep forgetting to tell that story.
We're drinking afterwards.
The hotel bar slow,
uh,
is about ready to shut down and I gotta leave at 6:40 AM flight.
So I'm like,
well,
what's the point of going to bed?
So I go across to this bar,
we start drinking over there and now their kitchen was closed.
So they bring out some bar food,
you know,
and they usually bring out some peanuts or pretzels.
They came out and it was all bacon.
I got to fucking tell you,
you can't beat the fucking Midwest,
even though that's not the Midwest.
It's the beginning of it.
And I forgot to mention,
uh,
Cleveland,
don't sleep on Cleveland.
I would say if you look into invest some money in buying an old building,
if you want some friends and you want to make some fucking money,
uh,
every time I come back to Cleveland it's,
it's doing a little bit better.
And I saw a lot of building going on there and it was great to see,
cause whenever I went to Cleveland it always made me sad like I was cause you,
you know,
I was looking at these beautiful buildings,
there was just nobody in them.
The same thing when you go to Detroit,
it's just like a,
yeah like fuck man,
look at these beautiful houses and these beautiful buildings.
And it was just like nobody there or just,
you know,
some Zombie looking person in front of it.
It's a,
it's depressing.
So in St Louis was another one.
St Louis was another one that was a scary place to be.
And 10 years ago,
you know,
they still have this shit,
if some people who are late to the show or couldn't come to the show because
there was a shooting or something like that.
So whatever,
everybody's got this shit.
But it was nice to see those cities are starting to make a comeback.
Um,
you know,
after all the manufacturing jobs and everything left and shit.
So I,
yeah,
I actually learned some shit about buffalo first city,
uh,
in,
in the United States that had electricity throughout the whole thing was used to
be known as the city of lights.
How funny is that?
Buffalo?
You don't think of that shit,
but I guess the Erie Canal or some shit.
Damn.
I don't know.
What the fuck are,
was creative bunch of jobs and then they built another dam or a canal somewhere
else up to fucking river.
And everybody left.
And that was the end of it.
You know,
everybody left,
all the pussies left,
you know,
but all the tough people stayed and that's why they have an outdoor stadium.
If those pussy stayed,
the buffalo bills would play in a dome stadium.
That's actually true.
All right,
so there you go.
That's a podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves.
My next date I have coming up is,
uh,
the Cape Cod melody tent in Hyannis,
Massachusetts.
Um,
tickets are on sale.
I hope people come out to that one.
That's a huge one because for me,
cause I only saw George Carlin once in my life,
unfortunately,
I only saw him perform one time and I saw him at the Cape Cod melody tent in
like 1988.
I've told that story a absolutely blew me away.
Uh,
Dennis Blair opening them up blew me away.
It was just,
it was fucking awesome.
And uh,
it's actually be going back there 25 years later to be literally doing what I
saw him doing.
His is fucking amazing.
So,
uh,
thanks to everyone who's coming out to that show.
All right.
And up at the field,
good vibes.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.
Uh,
go Bruins.
Okay.
Now that the show's over,
don't forget us to support our sponsors,
go to,
uh,
set up the free trial of he voice.
Join thousands of entrepreneurs who use their voice,
personal receptionist 24 seven right now.
Get a voice for 30 days.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com Promo Code Bill.
That's [inaudible] dot com Promo Code Bill.
Um,
and Hulu plus,
as I mentioned,
start watching TV,
your favorite shows right now.
Go to the podcastPage@bird.com.
Click on the Hulu plus banner for you.
Extended free trial or Hulu plus.com/bill.